Well, it's great to see you tonight friends. This is
the kickoff to our Advent season Christmas
season and some of you might be a little unfamiliar with
that word Advent. It has Latin roots
and it really just means appearing or
coming and so the idea is that
in the context of Christianity. It represents a
couple different things. It represents first how we talk
about it in terms of the Old Testament Saints who were looking
forward to longing for waiting for the
Messiah to come which we now
know and celebrate in in Christ. Jesus being born,
right? That's that's the idea that we can look back and and join
with them as they were waiting for it. But also
as we're going to see over the next few weeks, it's more than just kind of
identifying with them and they're waiting there's more to it
than that. There's an element that we are still
waiting, too.
Now we're still waiting in a sense for Christ's second Advent.
His second appearing his second coming.
and that many of the same things that they were waiting for back in
the Old Testament waiting for that Messiah to bring
and things that we might even see glimpses of today. We're
actually still waiting for our hearts are longing
for them to come in full.
And we'll see glimpses of these things but in full later and
that is what we're celebrating with the word Advent in
this season.
I don't know about you, but it was a bit of a mind shift. I had
to turn on my my Christmas season in my head
even as we're seeing those songs. It took me a second to catch on that. We're
actually in Christmas now, but but Thanksgiving is
over and so here we are at Christmas if you played Christmas before Thanksgiving,
I'm sorry. That's your it's a problem. I
don't know about for you. But for me it is now we're into Christmas. And
so here we are as we go now what has traditionally
been used to Mark these weeks leading up to Christmas is
this sort of Advent wreath of
various forms of that. It's what's called an Advent
wreath and it has these candles that are lighted weekly
leading up to and kind of preparing our hearts
for Christmas Eve and Christmas Day.
And here's why we have a physical symbol
like this. It has it really no meaning in itself. But
it's it's a symbol of that anticipation as we
think ahead to each candle being lighted. It
keeps our minds on what it means for Jesus to be
born that there was a sense you think about the
Testament they were they were looking ahead looking forward we're doing the
same thing looking forward and there's there's an anticipation of
that middle candle being lighted at some point,
which is the one that simply symbolizes Jesus.
But they they felt waiting they felt anticipation. We
feel the same way.
But what it also points us to and this is what we hope this gets us
towards as we have this out for the next few weeks is we
hope that it reminds us that what we're longing for and what we're waiting for
with Christmas has nothing to do with toys or gifts.
or stuff in any way
it has everything to do with What A Savior
alone could do for us.
That every one of us has the same need that what we need most is
this salvation from our sins and that's what
we anticipate coming in Jesus. We celebrate has
come in Jesus as he came to do
exactly that thing that we needed.
So Advent, as I said positions are hearts
in the longing that the Old Testament Saints would have felt
we can identify and position our hearts there but
it also points us forward to what we are longing for as well
our full salvation one day where
we're out of this that we're in right now.
That the fullness of these things God's promise will one day be
fulfilled in full.
And it'll be fully promised and fully accomplished and
we have reason to believe it's on its way. We we've seen things but
it's not yet here.
And so we wait we watch and that's
Advent.
And so as we walk through the next couple weeks talking about these
specific words as we study at this way. Let
the Lord stir your heart.
to a sense of
Strength for today and bright. Hope for tomorrow.
Because of what he's done and what he will do.
In fact, that's the first word hope that we're going to study in this
Advent season tonight. We're going to look at Hope and so take your coffee of
God's word and turn with me to Matthew chapter 12.
Matthew chapter 12 if you didn't bring yours, there's one underneath one
of the seats in front of you potentially.
somewhere around you
But Matthew chapter 12 is where we're going to be looking starting
in verse 15 at this concept of
Hope.
Now that concept of Hope is pretty misunderstood in our world today.
We use the word. Hope a lot when we're talking about sports. For example,
like I really hope the Thunder win.
Pretty doubtful this year, but you know like you hope that
they win or or even like I hope that I get that scholarship
that you're looking for from school or
I hope that I get that promotion at work. There's there's
this this word hope that we use but it has this air
of uncertainty, doesn't it?
It's like man, I don't really know if it's gonna happen. I hope it
does that's how we use the word a lot, but biblical hope.
Is very different.
I love how the Bible project puts this where it talks about how the Hebrew
words for Hope do involve a
measure of waiting. Like like Noah in
the ark the word used. There is that he was waiting for the end, right? So
you just sitting there kind of
Waiting it out and he's waiting on God. Yes, but he's
waiting it out. That's one sense of the word. But the other one
the main word kava. The picture
is like a chord that is pulled tight and
there's a tension in it until you release it.
So think of a Bungie cord where you've you've pulled it tight and there's a
tension there. There's an expectation you feel until
something happens till something
changes.
That's the idea of of hope
that we're talking about with Advent. But but
here's the thing in both cases, whether it's the chord pulled tight
or whether it's no waiting.
That hope is fixed on a person.
Every time it's used in scripture. It's talking
about it fixed on a person you're waiting on something and
it's that thing is God.
The words for Hope are most often used in a crisis.
When nothing else is going right they have
to wait on God.
That even when there's no evidence things will get better you wait on
God that word. Wait is the same word for hope that's that's
the same in expectation that you've got this tightened out.
You're waiting to see what's going to happen.
That's the idea of Hope and a prophet in
the Old Testament named Jose is a great example of this.
See Hosea was facing the same
kind of trouble we've seen in Micah that Micah was facing over
those last few months. We walked through that book that that there were
these enemy and Nations entering the land and trying to take over
and they're pressing in and he was seeing it all around
him yet Hosea instead of worrying or
fearing he chose to Hope in God.
Because he prophesied this in Hebrews 215 that
God would turn the valley of trouble.
into a door of Hope
That's that word kava that that sense of
expectation waiting hoping.
The cord was pulled tight that God was going
to do something here. God was working this out. And so
he's expectant in that.
And here's how Jose do that. How did Hosea know that
so confidently because he looked back to the Exodus.
He looked back to what God had done to deliver his people out of
Egypt. He said God did it once God can do it again.
God had redeemed his people out of Egypt before surely he can
do it again. God can work like that again, so I'm expectant.
I'm waiting. I'm hoping.
In fact, that's the basis.
for all of our hope
It's God's past faithfulness that motivates
our future expectation.
We look forwardly by looking backwardly.
Like we look forward by looking backwards by
looking at what God has done. You
don't trust in the circumstances you face right now you
trust in God's character.
That's what gives you hope.
When you're facing whatever you face, that's what we're seeing here
in Matthew 12.
Now as a quick context this passage right before this passage
we're going to read today is that Jesus went into the synagogue and
he healed a man on the Sabbath day.
And the religious leaders, they came after Jesus when they saw him
do this and and they tried to trap Jesus which by
the way anytime you try to trap Jesus a bad idea.
But but that's what they were trying to do. And so what Jesus showed them
he flipped it and he said it's actually right to do
good on the Sabbath, isn't it? Like don't
you agree with me Pharisees they had
to of course.
and so they began to conspire against Jesus and
that leads us to the Cross eventually but right after
what he does he we see Matthew
record this Matthew 12 verse 15 down to
verse 21
Jesus aware of this this conspiring this
conspiring against him he withdrew from there and many
followed him and he healed them all and he
ordered them not to make him known.
And this was to fulfill what was spoken by the prophet Isaiah.
Behold my servant whom I've chosen my beloved
with whom my soul is well pleased. I will
put my spirit upon Him He will Proclaim Justice to the
Gentiles. He will not quarrel or cry aloud nor
will anyone here is voice in the streets a bruised
Reed. He will not break a smoldering Wick he
will not quench until he brings Justice to Victory
and in his name the Gentiles
will
hope
That's the word they will hope now. This
is nearly a direct quote from Isaiah 42.
Which Isaiah predicted about the Messiah 700
years before Jesus showed up
and said this was what he was going to be like and so right away Matthew's showing
Jesus fulfills the prophecies. That
was Matthew's argument. He's saying Jesus is this Messiah
folks but notice how and
when Matthew does this?
He positions this this Messianic fulfillment
in the middle.
Of Jesus healing people and declaring freedom
from the Sabbath law this
legalistic interpretation of it that the
Pharisees had been doing.
He's going to heal and he's going to reinterpret the law. And and then
he also says not just is this Messiah coming
for the Jewish people? He's coming for the Gentiles as
well twice. He mentions that
now the Gentiles remember those are the people who are non-ethnically Jewish.
That means anybody who's not Israel is a
gentile.
And so in Matthew saying here is this prophesied
Messiah was coming to bring Justice to
the Gentiles.
Now when you hear he's bringing Justice to someone that means
by definition there's an injustice happening, right?
It's got to bring Justice to them because they're not getting Justice right
now is Injustice happening.
Well, what were they experiencing did Gentiles remember
we're cut off?
from the hope of Israel
They had lesser access to God in the
temple. They had lesser access to God in other ways. And so
they had no hope.
In fact the Greek word in the New Testament that is used for
despair.
Is actually the word a compound word
that says away from Hope.
Like the Gentiles were Cast Away from hope so they were despairing when
they had hope as Israel that they
were hoarding a little here.
But Matthew says that's not the way the Messiah is going to
be. He's going to be God's representative. He's going to be the one who would
not cast off the Gentiles but he would instead gently and
Tenderly and quietly and carefully care for
and restore those who were lost.
That would be Justice.
Because it would align with God's right way with God's heart
for the Nations. We've seen this if you've been around church here for
any length of time you've seen as we go back to the very beginning
of Genesis. This is God's heart. He's for the
Nations not just for one. He's for all nations that
that's Justice to God is that all nations
would be included in this and so he's coming to
bring hope as the Savior Messiah to
All Nations.
Which by the way that's why we have stars everywhere around here right
this season.
So why the the decoration will work on tonight is stars is
because back in Genesis 12 God promised to
Abraham that his descendants would be more numerous than the
stars in the sky.
Remember kids that's where Abraham gets told by God to walk
outside and try to count the Stars.
Go home and do that tonight, right? I'm gonna go outside. I'm gonna count
the stars in the sky you can't
And God said Abraham, that's how many descendants you're
going to have now. That's that's a lot.
And the symbol is that God is going to open this Covenant
of Salvation up to the Nations and
it will be countless how many people God will
be able to save through that that's why we
have stars here because what we see in Jesus the
Messiah is the Fulfillment.
As he has come to be the one to bring
about that salvation.
And so these Saints of old.
Could look back.
At God's fulfillment of his promises in Exodus especially
and they could have hope as they waited on
God for him to deliver them again.
That was why they kept repeating it throughout the Old Testament Exodus Exodus
Exodus. Remember that remember that don't forget that don't forget
that because that gave them encouragement and hope today.
That God had defeated their most powerful
enemy before.
Egypt
so he could do it again, right?
He would do it again.
But listen, that's the same kind of hope we today Church.
That we gentiles.
can have
like they look back and said God defeated Egypt. What do
we have to fear today? We can look today that we what
similar to God doing that in Exodus. We were
born in slave to our most powerful enemy
sin and we were enslaved to
its process. It's it's end it's never
ending penalty, which is death what that was where we were
that we are in our own sin.
And yet God defeated our most powerful enemy.
How did he do that? He did that through his life death and
Resurrection. His cross has empty tomb are symbols that
he defeated death and when he opened the tomb that
opened the door of hope for us.
It's what first Peter 1:3 says that according to God's Great
Mercy. He's caused us to be born again to a Living
Hope.
Through the resurrection of Jesus Christ from the dead that hope we
have makes us new it's alive. It's something
that should give us a sense of expectation that
the core has been pulled and one day he's coming back.
So just like the Old Testament Saints placed their hope not
in their circumstances they placed their hope in a person.
It's the same for us. Our hope is in Jesus the Overcomer of
death our greatest enemy sin and death the
overcomeer of that Jesus Christ. That's what his first Advent
does.
When we look at Christmas, that's what he came to do. What
his first appearance does it provides for us
strength for today. Hope for tomorrow because of
what his overcoming work did for us.
But again, we said this the whole time.
Not only are we hoping in his first Advent there's a sense
where we're still waiting for the Fulfillment of
these things as well. These this full fulfillment
of Hope because because we know this is not complete
yet.
Well that of course is coming someday in the future at that second
Advent his second appearing his second coming.
Where he will remove us from the very presence of sin.
That's that's a beautiful sense of hope that we can
have.
That is coming someday, but listen
church, that is how we as Christians can have hope today.
That all of that is how we can have hope today.
We're talking about this earlier this week
and I love last week. Actually, I talked to it with Phil about this and
he was give this great illustration. I got to give him credit for it. So
this is yours Phil.
It's like whenever you you record the the game
the big game, let's say football game.
You record the game and you've gone to something. You got a wedding or you've
got something else that you've got to go to and you can't watch it at all. But you record it
and you're trying to go full radio silence on this thing to make
sure you don't hear who wins. So you go back and watch it like it's live, right?
Skip the commercials which is better right you want to do it. That way
you go full radio silence to try to keep this but somebody
spills the beans.
Frustrating that is that you now know the final score and you know your team
won.
And it's kind of exciting but it's also kind of disappointing because you wanted to watch it
that way, but but think about this.
Think about how you go home and now watch that game a little bit differently,
don't you?
Like, you know the outcome already.
You know the end score, you know, your team
wins, you know all of it. Think about how you watch it. The fumbles
don't matter as much anymore.
Right the penalty that ref missed clearly
the holding right you miss that one.
Yeah.
What about when the the team at the like late in the
fourth quarter, they throw a pick six and the team runs it back and and
the other team gets ahead and you're like, oh man. Yeah, that's bad. But
it's not that big a deal right you watch the game very differently.
Why because you know the end result already.
You know that your team wins.
And so that's the idea we get here the same way when our lives now
what if since we know the end of
the story what if our hope is higher than the headlines?
What if our hope is going beyond anything that's happening right
now in the world happening on CNN or Fox News
or whatever you watch like it's it's above that the hope is way up
here not conditional here.
What if we have a hope that we can cling to while the nation's rage
around us? We have hope.
What if we had hope in the Lord like Psalm 130 describes
for with the Lord there is steadfast love
and with him. There is plentiful Redemption.
See the only way
That we can have genuine hope in the face of Earthly circumstances
is to put our hope
in something that is out of the reach of
our surroundings.
you know like if you
so so kids.
If Mom puts the cookies on the counter, you
can reach those, right?
But if if she puts the cookies above the cabinet.
You can't get there.
So the same thing if we're putting our hope in something that's on the cabinet
level here.
The enemy can come snatch that away really fast. He can
take it away from any angle all this and we can't put our hope
there if we put our hope in something that's Out Of Reach of our circumstances then
that's secure.
That's what we're talking about with this Advent idea.
That's what Advent does.
Is it reminds us to put our hope in God alone?
To put our hope above our surroundings as
we celebrate what he has done in his first Advent and
all the work he did in his life. But we also anticipate what
he will do someday in his second Advent.
We look forward by Looking Backward.
We look forward by Looking Backward. We're trusting the character of
God that our eternity is secure because what he's done for us.
That's biblical hope and it's what we celebrate at Christmas.
at this God Has Come In the Flesh once
and he's coming back again. Someday In the Flesh just like
he did and so we wait with hope.
See, that's the candle that we are going to light tonight.
The first candle of advent is hope the
candle of Hope.
And so as we go through the process of the next few weeks
of lighting all of these you're going to hear those words, you're going to talk about each of
those words separately. But tonight. The first one is hope
I'm invite the the wheat family up here tonight to help lead
us through this tonight as we as
we celebrate the beginning of Advent and
Jay and Brady and Wendy Also Serve Faithfully in
many ways in our kids ministry and their family is
going to light the candle as they read scripture and
pray for us as we continue to worship
tonight.
Isaiah 11:1 through 10 there shall
come forth a shoot from the stump of Jesse and
a branch from his roots shell bear fruit and the
spirit of the Lord shall rest upon him the spirit of wisdom and
understanding the spirit of counsel and might the
spirit of knowledge and the fear of the Lord and his Delight
shall be in the fear of the Lord. He shall not judge by
what he's by what his eyes see or decide despite
what his ears hear but with righteousness
he shall judge the poor and decide with equity for
the meek of the earth and he shall strike the Earth
with the rod of his mouth and with the breath of his lips. He
shall kill the wicked righteousness shall be the
belt of his waste and faithfulness the belt of his loins the
wolf shall dwell with the lamb and the
leopard shall lie down with the young goat in the calf
and The Lion and the fat and calf together and the
little child shall lead them the cow and the bear
shall Grace their young shall lie down together and the
lion shall eat straw like the ox
The nursing child shall play over the whole of the
Cobra and the weaned child shall put his hand at
the adder's Den. They shall not hurt or destroy
in all the Holy Mountain.
For the Earth shall be full of the knowledge of the Lord as the
waters cover the sea in that day the root
of Jesse who shall stand as a signal for his peoples of
him. Shall the nations in choir and has resting place
shall be glorious.
Let's pray.
God thank you for giving us the ability to
come together and worship and celebrate you in this
season.
Thank you for sending your Messiah.
To rescue us from sin and death and Conquer it.
Thank you for the hope of yours. Your son's
return.
Thank you for the hope that we will rejoice with
you. I pray that you would just soften soften our
hearts. Give us peace during this season
allow us to be the vessel.
This shines your light so that others can see your glory.
Also understand that the reason we we
even have this season is because of you.
amen